the point of these two lectures is
really this Harry Blackmun said when i
came i was i was appointed after he said
you know III wish i had written down
what I'd learned over the years you know
so I thought well I might try you know
that that is a risk I mean that is a
serious risk because you end up like the
famous George Bernard Shaw you know who
told the judge the judge said my god he
said I have to deliver everything I know
about law and the commencement speech
next Friday what will I do and Shaw said
both speak very slowly of it but so so
there is a risk in this and in a sense
what I'm going to do today is sort of
like a spoonful of sugar helps the
medicine go down this is sort of the
sugar and tomorrow is the medicine and
what I'm trying to do is put down in a
form that people will understand and not
just law students but people who aren't
lawyers aren't law students what I find
so moving and so significant about being
in the job that I've been in the last 15
years I mean I see in front of me every
single day people by race religion color
point of view whatever I've told this
story four thousand times and Joanna
said if she hears it once more she's
walking out so don't walk out but about
the book the point is it's true and my
mother is another part of the story said
that because we were from San Francisco
when you say she said there's no view so
mad that there isn't someone in the
United States who doesn't hold it and
then she said they all live in Los
Angeles but the the point the point is
we do see in front of us everyone and
they're there to decide things that are
dividing them under law I can say that
about 5,000 times and it's pretty hard
to capture the emotional content of it
so what I thought I do in this first
part you see the first part tries to
capture the emotional content of that
and the second part says well what
should the court do in order to be sure
it's still there 10 15 20 25 50 years
from now
the answer is we can't do much about it
but we could try and so that's tomorrow
today is to try to give an answer that I
give often to a question it's often
asked I'll see judges from South America
LC judges from Africa I see judges from
around the world who come to our court
they want to see our court they've heard
of it and they want to see it and nine
times out of ten I will get the
following question why does it work and
after they've heard the argument they
really pushed that question what why in
heaven's name does this work I say well
the Constitution I said I take it out
usually that's impressive I say about
why the Constitution's a small document
written in very general words after
you've been there for a while you can
summarize the main points and I usually
summarize them by saying look up it
creates in those seven articles it
creates a set of institutions that are
basically democratic institutions they
are there for people where citizens of
the United States and can vote to choose
the kind of government they want it's
basically about democracy now it's a
certain kind of democracy it's a
democracy that protects basic rights
certain ones it assures a degree of
equality it divides power horizontally
three branches vertically state-federal
so no group of people become too
powerful within the government and it
insists upon a rule of law and the rest
is sort of detailed filling that in I
say well it is a special kind of
democracy and those principles have
helped us and that means that what we do
in the court we don't say what people
should do at least that's not how we see
it what we see it is that that court
that Constitution is a creating a set of
boundaries and we are like the boundary
Patrol we're like the frontier police
we're trying to keep this system on the
rail now life in the frontier is
anyone who grew up as we did and used to
listen who was that person the mound
he's somebody sky king of the Mounties
or something was on the radio at
five-fifteen he was out on frontier and
life was tough it's not so easy on that
frontier and they're very difficult
questions which side of the boundary
does abortion followed which side of the
boundary is school prayer which side of
the boundary is this or that there are a
lot of difficult arguments that divide
people enormously but it's important to
remember that it is a boundary and
within those boundaries is a vast area
where people in fact make decisions for
themselves how through their elected
representatives about what kind of
community they want on thousands and
thousands and thousands of topics so
let's not get mixed up about our
relation to the whole system i would say
we're basically the boundary patrol and
i've explained this to many many of
these foreign judges they actually know
that isn't really what we're interested
in I said what are you what are you
injured why do people do what you say
that they want to know why do they do it
we're the boundary Patrol great but
we're nine people and there are a lot of
distinguished judges here we can add
them in a Guido in at others we make it
nine hundred ninety nine hundred and
twenty maybe a thousand out a lot of
judges still it's a small number why do
people particularly when we do decide
things like abortion that's just a very
very mild unemotional matter that goes
to the heart of about twenty thirty
forty fifty sixty or seventy percent of
how people feel in the United States
strongly and we do decide that and
people do it roughly why that's what
they want to know one of them said oh we
think it's CEO you control the US
Marshals I like the US Marshals they're
very decent people and they do their job
well but I don't think even they could
bring about enforcement of the Supreme
Court opinions
if in fact people were not willing to do
it so what is it I really want to tell
those judges those judges from Latin
America the judges from Africa the
judges from other parts of the world who
want to know the secret I want to tell
them that there isn't much of a secret
but there is a lot of history and I'd
like to illustrate that in the next 30
or 40 minutes skimming through three or
four cases so that you can see what I
see from my seat on the court as an
America that hasn't always been like it
is at the moment in respect to how
people feel about Court decisions and
the law now there's approximately fifty
or sixty thousand books on the subject
of where did the Supreme Court ever get
the power to start reviewing acts of
Congress and holding them
unconstitutional and probably of the
fifty or sixty thousand fifty nine
thousand eight hundred and thirty-two
think it probably is a thoroughly bad
idea or at least not as good an idea as
some other people in writing other books
though now I have not read all those
books but I've read a little bit about
it and it seems to me that we are there
in a world where we do have this power
but how did it come about well I've
learned two things from that very
ancient history from reading a few
things that others have written and the
first is why did Congress know the
president know Alexander Hamilton while
we're getting warmer the founders why
did they give the court the power to set
aside acts of Congress to have the last
word about was was or was not
constitutional so when I read that I
discover either interesting debate and
this is only my view and it seems to me
in my view most of those founders
thought that the court would have the
last word at least in some areas at
least as to some part
to the Constitution in some situations
and they thought someone has to have the
last word read Hamilton again and again
and say do you think that the court
should have the last word about whether
an act of Congress is constitutional I
think you'll come to the conclusion he
says yes say why why why do you think
that what's so great about the court
they're not even elected and I think he
says this nothing nothing is so great
about the court it's just that the
others are worse suppose we gave the
power of having the last word to the
president my goodness he could become a
dictator he could do anything he wanted
all right let's give it to congress to
congress hmm if this document is meant
to keep Congress inbounds this document
in part is designed to protect the least
popular person in the United States when
all of the others want to tearin' eyes
over them and you think that Congress
that has just passed this law which just
ruins some individual because it's
popular to ruin that individual you
think that Congress is going to turn
around and say oh the very law we pass
is unconstitutional he says I doubt it I
doubt it they are subject to the popular
will immediately and two ships in the
popular will immediately and that causes
a problem if we're going to give them
the last word we risk not having the
those boundaries in this document
enforced now who does that leave well
the Interstate Commerce Commission had
not been founded at that time but who
does that leave that leaves a nice group
of people actually we love them very
decent underpaid but nuns nonetheless
nonetheless this group of people called
judges as Hamilton first they're pretty
technical people pretty technical and
they're not likely to cause too much
trouble they don't have the power of
purse they don't have the power of the
sword and they basically do their job
and they won't hold laws of Congress
unconstitutional too often he thought
and so let's give it to them fine we'll
give them the power and I think many
many of the founders were thinking that
way but they didn't write it into the
Constitution it doesn't say a word about
it there's nothing in this document that
tells us who's going to have the last
word or even the medium last word and
therefore we think what well we think
maybe Chief Justice Marshall somehow
sees this power which he didn't he
ratified what people were thinking at
the time now remember what they're
thinking they're thinking that the
judges basically are the least
threatening group of people to enforce
the boundaries that are in this document
and that's not a bad argument compared
to the others but then there is the
question that those African judges and
the Asian judges and the Latin American
judges asked me which Hamilton seems not
to address well Shakespeare put the
question I love this line I work for
arthur goldberg and it was his favorite
line it's when owen glendower is saying
typical Welshman thinks Shakespeare sort
of mystical he says i can summon spirits
from the vasty deep and hotspur look
seven and says well so can I so can any
man but will they come when you do call
them
indeed that is the question and look to
see what Hamilton says about that I
found nothing nothing but that question
seems to run through case after case
after case as we look along the course
of American history in the court let's
look at the founding case the founding
case Marbury vs. Madison everyone knows
that one know what actually happened in
Marbury vs. Madison what happened was
the Federalist lost the election of 1800
terrible now Jefferson is running the
country the Republicans are running the
country and Marshall and the Federalists
have nothing left but the Supreme Court
and Jefferson has said each of the three
departments has an equal right to decide
for itself its duty under the
Constitution without regard to what
others may have decided under a similar
question that doesn't seem very
promising for the doctrine of judicial
review moreover Jefferson and the
Republicans are worried about the
Federalists and they would like to do
them in if they can the Federalists by
the way had not behaved impeccably just
before they went out of office they did
all kinds of things to improve the
position of the judiciary and including
appointing a whole lot of new judges
they recalled the midnight judges they
were Federalist we will have Federalists
now in Federalist positions this is the
last bastion of power one of the people
who was appointed was named Marbury and
Marbury was never delivered his
commission who was the person who was
supposed to deliver the commission it
was John Marshall actually John Marshall
was Secretary of State at that time he
was on his way to the Supreme Court I
guess in the rush she forgot to deliver
the Commission Marberry didn't get it we
have a new president now Thomas
Jefferson and a new secretary of state
and Marbury says where is my commission
to be a judge and they say we're not
giving it to you hahaha or something to
that effect
so what did Marberry do he brought a
lawsuit and he said they have to I've
been appointed I was appointed by
President Adams I'm entitled to my
office what are they doing not giving me
this piece of paper and now we have the
great case Marbury versus Madison but
where is Marbury going to sue are we
sure he can find a court it will give
him this piece of paper and now along
comes a very very technical statute
which seems as if it is going to give
two mar break the right that he's
entitled to what does this statute says
it says the Supreme Court says the
statute can issue writs of mandamus in
cases warranted by the principles and
usages of law to any person holding
office under the authority of the United
States that sounds good and indeed he
Sue's in the Supreme Court and Marshall
and the Supreme Court decide the case do
they give him this this is a very
important decision why well the first
thing that Marshall says for the court
is easy entitled is Marbury entitled to
the Commission under the usages of law
does law entitle them to the Commission
answer yes of course I mean he was
appointed he has a 5-year term nothing
left to do but hand him a piece of paper
the law entitles don't do it is this the
kind of case that we could in fact give
order mandamus which means do your job
yes this is that kind of case this is a
ministerial job it's just mechanical
it's like we walk into the clerk's
office in any kind of marriage bureau or
something I want my certificate here's
the three dollars give it to me give him
the certificate yes he's entitled to it
there's no politics involved here this
isn't a political decision and do we
have the power to give it to him
this statute says we have the power
statute says we have the power yes I
guess we could give it to it ah but wait
if we look at the Constitution the
Constitution says that we in the Supreme
Court can give take an action you're a
complaint here a claim when when there
is a case it was brought here as this
one was affecting ambassadors is no
ambassador here public ministers and
councils none of them goes in which a
state shall be a party nope those are
the cases where you can bring a claim
directly in the Supreme Court you're not
listed mr. Marbury not listed and so we
have the Constitution not giving us the
power to hear your case as an original
matter and we have you entitled to your
red but do we follow the statute which
seems to entitle you to the writ from us
ordering it or do we follow the
Constitution now finally at the end of
this opinion we're at this great
question and Joe Marshall says it's not
such a difficult question not a very
difficult question at all in fact if we
see the Constitution here and the
statute here and there's a conflict well
we have a written constitution this is
more powerful and more important than
the other uh we have to follow the
Constitution all right simple Houdini
why Whodini because who won the case
Jefferson won the case now look what
Marshall has done Marvel has said
Jefferson you violated the law Marbury
you're entitled to this commission of
but we can't hold you mr. president you
can't say you
have to give it to him because we don't
have the power to do so because the
statute giving us the power violates the
Constitution now why do I say Houdini
you see Jefferson thought he had marshal
in a box how is Marshall going to decide
this case he's either going to decide in
Marbury's favor or against Marbury if he
decides against Marbury he's proved that
the court doesn't even have the power to
give this poor man that piece of paper
which he's clearly entitled to and he's
shown that the court is weak if on the
other hand he says give him the paper I
won't do it I won't do it too bad and
then he shown it's doubly week now why
do we think Maura Jefferson we don't
know Jefferson wouldn't have done it but
we do know Jefferson told Madison who
was the respondent in the case don't
show up don't even set foot in court
that gives us a hint and we know quite a
few of the things Jefferson said so
certainly there was quite a threat that
Jefferson would not carry out an order
of the court and what Marshall has done
is established more power than Jefferson
ever thought was likely he can review
acts of Congress and hold him
unconstitutional he said that Marbury is
entitled to this piece of paper but
Jefferson wins so he can't complain now
what's the theme that that's
illustrating to me it's Hotspurs
question it's Hotspurs question I mean
Marshall doesn't know what's going to
happen if he orders Jefferson to give
this piece of paper to mr. Marbury and
he's worried that the court just won't
be obeyed and therefore Chief Justice
Marshall being worried calls upon
Houdini Marshall to get him out of the
jam
and he did now was he right to be
worried all right let's look at two or
three examples was he right to be
worried by the way the court didn't hold
another statute unconstitutional
probably didn't there's some argument
about this but until this decision of
Dred Scott in eight and then when they
held statutes unconstitutional they did
it in quite a big way I mean that was a
terrible case but that's many many years
into the future they did decide cases
that were almost constitutional cases of
the sort were interested in cases for
example involving the Cherokee Indians
where popularity is all on one side
where it's very important where there
are victims and where the court is going
to have to hold under the law in favor
of those victims so let's look at that
case for a minute a case involving the
Cherokee Indians in 1829 1830 the tribe
of Cherokee Indians lived in northern
Georgia now they could live there it's
their land they're guaranteed this land
by treaty and the Constitution says the
treaties just like this one it says in
article six are the supreme law of the
land just like the Constitution is the
turkeys aren't worried by the way
they've abandoned all their hunting and
fishing they have farms they have an
alphabet they have a constitution they
have a great leader called chief Ross
and he is civilized in the quotes I mean
of the period he would be a civilized
person in that period far more so than
his northern Georgia neighbors and the
northern Georgia neighbors are real
troublemakers by the way one reason was
of course in 1829 they found gold we're
in the Cherokee land now they've been
behaving reasonably all the Georgians
till that moment but once the gold was
found and why should they have it the
Indians why shouldn't we have him we're
Georgians they're Indians and we'll take
it and they marched right in and they
did take it and they made all kinds of
laws governing the charities now
remember chief Ross has a constitution
they're there just indistinguishable
from their neighbors as farmers and he
does what any good man or woman but the
Constitution would do when in trouble
hire a lawyer and he hires the great
lawyer of the day Willard work who was
later Attorney General and word says
don't worry I've read the Constitution
I've read it I mean there's a treaty I
mean you're entitled to this land I mean
the Georgians don't have a legal ground
to stand on fine good what are you going
to do mr. Wert where it says one can
bring a lawsuit now that's easier said
than done why because the last time
there was a lawsuit brought in a similar
manner in this particular place
involving the creeks the creeks did in
fact win that tribe but the Georgians
passed the law saying anyone who comes
in to execute this order of a court in
favor of the creeks will himself be
executed in quite a different way then
there to show that they meant it there
was a case involving corn tassel who was
a Cherokee and he won to accept before
the court order could get to him they
hanged him hmm he's gonna have some
problems mr. word what is he going to do
well the first thing he does is he
brings a famous case called Cherokee
Indian cherokee nation versus georgia
and the trouble there is that the
supreme court found a kind of
technicality and odd interpretation of a
jurisdictional point and didn't decide
the case but then luckily for the
Cherokees a missionary from
Massachusetts named wistar came to the
Cherokee land lived there was trying to
help them out and the governor of
Georgia way ahead of his time asked him
to sign a loyalty oath to Georgia and he
wouldn't and therefore the governor of
Georgia and the Georgian troops put him
in jail now here is the case works the
lighted because it's unlikely he'll
execute someone from Massachusetts not
definite but probably not in the same
way that they
executed corn tassel now he has his case
because any competing he can appeal this
all the way to the Supreme Court and he
did and in the Supreme Court he won he
won won the case fine why not let me
read you this is story because they
didn't he didn't know justice story is
sitting with Justice Marshall he say he
wrote to his wife thanks be to God the
court can wash their hands clean of the
iniquity of oppressing the Indians and
disregarding their rights the court has
done its duty now let the nation do
there's good and he added the Georgia is
full of anger and violence probably she
will resist and if she does I do not
believe the president will interfere
indeed that's what happened the
president was Andrew Jackson he did not
interfere he said to the court in effect
in effect no one knows if he really said
this but certainly people think he did
john marshall has made his decision now
let him enforce it and officials in the
jackson administration said lots of
things to that effect such as the
president has just as good a right to
interpret the Constitution as the
supreme court just as good right and so
why should I bother being president to
enforce this piece of paper that the
court puts up and he wouldn't at that
point Joseph story Marshall wrote the
story I yield slowly and reluctantly to
the conviction that our Constitution
cannot last why why not why was it so
important to follow the court well
Jackson found out pretty quickly because
South Carolina was observing what would
happened and someone in South Carolina
had a really brilliant idea said well if
Georgia doesn't have to pay attention to
the court or particular provisions in
the Constitution as they interpret it
there are a few others that we would
like not to pay attention to one of them
being collecting customs duties and
giving them to federal government so
they passed a law saying don't pay any
of the federal customs duties as long as
you're in North Carolina great idea now
even Jackson figured out that was not
such a good idea and at that point he
became a little worried about the
situation he went to Congress got them
to pass a force bill which meant that he
had the power to send troops down to
South Carolina South Carolina saw what
was happening and withdrew its law at
that point what about poor wistar who's
in jail the newspapers start writing
editorials saying nobody can see the
difference between whisper being in jail
in this place and the customs duty and
the other place except for a supporter
of Jackson and governor of Georgia
worked this out and Jackson worked it
out and they reached an agreement and
whisker was released from jail all right
so it has a happy ending doesn't it I
mean whispers released no doesn't have a
happy end doesn't have one bit of a
happy end what happened next is the
Jackson sent troops maybe he should have
done this little earlier that he sent
troops into Georgia did he send troops
to defend the Indians no he sent troops
to evict them he found a handful of
people who would sign a treaty agreeing
to go and as soon as the 17,000 others
discovered this they rioted and said no
one wants to leave Jackson's general
said no one wanted to leave but Congress
ratified this treaty by a vote of one
majority and the troops went down in
terrible circumstances terrible
circumstances and sent the Indians on
their way Trail of Tears to Oklahoma
where their descendants live to this day
so if this is a story of Hotspur I'd say
the story is that Hotspur seems to be
right I mean will they come when you
call them well certainly the court right
there had the experience of saying a
seeing no yeah very unpopular a few
people against the many and they're in
Oklahoma they're not in Georgia
let's roll the camera forward if you'd
like I'd like to spend some time talking
about Brad Scott but there isn't time so
you have to come to a different lecture
which I will give in April on in a
different place in New York on that
subject but roll it forward a little
more to where we get to the point where
actually i was born i find this
interesting and a a case that i like to
contrast or not contrast because it's a
kind of middle case is Cooper versus
Aaron not everyone knows what Cooper vs.
Aaron hands Cooper vs. Aaron came along
after Brown versus Board of Education in
Brown versus Board of Education the
court said and it's so easy in
retrospect in retrospect you look just
open your eyes look around there was in
fact a provision of the Constitution
which says all people are entitled to
equal protection of the laws that was
passed because we had a war in which
slavery was abolished and there were a
lot of people who are going to be
treated unequally and Congress did not
want them to be treated unequally they
wanted them to be treated equally and by
1954 1955 although there'd been some
experiments was separate but equal in
plessy v ferguson if you wanted to know
whether people were treated equally if
they were african-americans in the south
all you had to do was open your eyes and
look and they worked and it was pretty
bad so finally in 1954 in brown the
court got around to saying ok here's the
Constitution it says and maybe it was a
little more difficult than that but it
said the idea here is these people will
be treated equally and they're not okay
so end go no more segregation let's
apply the law to everyone alike and they
set ideals in that opinion it's a pretty
good opinion there's flat in its
language question is it separate but is
is is it constitutional does it violate
the Constitution to have segregated
schools no yes it does it does violate
the Constitution it's simple and it's
clear and that's because at least to us
the issue is simple and
and it's unanimous now the court has a
problem there's about a third of the
country that seems fairly upset about
this and they might not do it again it's
hots for his problem and the court then
and people debate the wisdom of this
about a year later decided Brown to and
use the famous words with all deliberate
speed their will in fact be
desegregation that's what will happen
next will desegregate with deliberate
speed and we can debate whether it
should have said with deliberate speed
or it should have said do it now but did
say deliberate speed and I don't know it
would have made much a difference if
they said do it now because what
happened over the next year was nothing
nothing happened well not quite nothing
there was desegregation starting in the
District of Columbia in a handful of
cities but throughout most of the south
I think it's fair to say nothing at all
was happening in Texas there was a court
order that said that there had to be a
beginning of desegregation and the
governor was against it and said I'm not
going to do it and nothing really
happened so what we have the great
declaration and we have an opinion
that's saying now we're going to do
something and at least begin and we have
happening nothing well in nineteen by
nineteen fifty-seven in Little Rock a
school board which had not been
tremendously in favor of segregation the
school board said decided that they
would begin desegregation we'll start
with the high schools and just a few one
central high school and we'll begin
slowly and then we'll go down to the
lower grades and eventually a few years
from now we'll have our schools
beginning to be desegregated the
n-double-a-cp was against that they
thought it was too slow the court said
it's good enough begin and there were
court orders to say that in September in
September of 1957 there will be some
black students in that white school
some of you can remember that there were
nine students that recall the Little
Rock Nine they were pretty brave they
were chosen particularly because they
were great and because they were they
were they were intelligent they did good
job in school they live not too far away
they satisfied a lot of criteria and so
the court said them they are the ones
they should enter Little Rock High
School when it opens in September well
easier said than done why is there were
a lot of things going on in Little Rock
at that time there were there in
Congress the representatives of the
South we're saying that the Supreme
Court decision was totally illegal they
wrote something called the southern
manifesto we'd said the court has no
business doing this there were white
citizens councils that said the state
should interpose itself between the
court and the order whatever that
mounted sounded quite good it meant that
the state wouldn't do it there were
people who were threatening violence
there were threats and there was
violence there were lynchings in
Mississippi and the till being a famous
one it was a bad situation but the
little skull the Little Rock School
Board had said we are going to go ahead
and whole and integrate Little Rock's
Central High School beginning September
third 1957 what happened governor Faubus
who had not been elected as a great
segregationist he'd been sort of middle
of the road he became convinced that
segregation was the key to his political
future I suppose and on August
twenty-ninth he went to a state court
and got the state court to order the
federal court not to order the school
integration well that worked for about
three days then the n-double-a-cp went
back to the federal court and they set
that aside
still it's now February's now September
third the federal court says we ought to
wait a couple of days here till things
settle down they were trying to
coordinate the entry everyone got the
word except Elizabeth Eckford who didn't
have a telephone who was one of the
Little Rock Nine and she showed up at
the high school the morning there was a
big crowd outside and it was news all
over the world and someone took a
picture and it's a famous picture she's
walking very dignified and behind her
there is a white woman whose face is
absolutely contorted in rage in that
picture went around the world and they
said this is this is segregation or
desegregation or integration we don't
know which whatever is happening in the
rock in the United States on Thursday
the federal court said I want the FBI
and the Department of Justice to show up
in my court to see if the governor is
really helping enforce this order or
hindering the governor sent the National
Guard he didn't send the National Guard
to help with integration he sent the
National Guard to try to prevent the
integration well at this point there was
a congressman from little Brock haze of
Brooks and he was kind of moderate and
he knew Eisenhower who is president and
he said let's set up a meeting here
between the governor and the president
governor Faubus flew off to meet with
the president at Newport and as he later
described it he said the president
dressed me down like an army captain
addressing a lieutenant or a private and
I didn't like it he might not have liked
it but he gave President Eisenhower the
impression that he would go along and
see that the school was integrated then
he went out of the room and he gave the
newspapers a different impression and
President Eisenhower didn't like that
very much
he thought that wasn't a very
particularly good way to behave so we
have a governor who says I have the
troops and I've told them not to let
anybody in the school and when the
federal court orders me to withdraw the
troops which it did I'll withdraw them
and now all we have as a school in the
middle of Arkansas surrounded by 1500
white citizen council members and
various other troublemakers and into
this school these nine students are
supposed to walk what happened over the
next week or so was nobody did anything
I mean you're not going to send the nine
students no matter how brave they are
into that school Eisenhower is thinking
what should I do now it's interesting is
to read how he was advised Jimmy Byrnes
who was the former governor of South
Carolina former member of the Supreme
Court a great friend of Harry Truman and
very active in World War two flew up to
talk to Eisenhower and he said to
Eisenhower you cannot intervene if you
intervene you're going to have to have
the second reconstruction of the south
you are going to see somebody will get
hurt you won't how to get the troops out
of there there will be violence they'll
close the schools if they close the
schools nobody will get educated and he
was pretty strong apparently about not
doing anything Eisenhower saw brownell
his attorney general his wise counselor
and brownell said you have to do
something now because what's at stake is
the rule of law now people debate how
much I think there are two sides to this
debate after reading quite a lot of
validate about how much Eisenhower was
really in favor of integration I mean he
might well have been very much in favor
of that he did integrate he liked to
lead through example and people who know
him said that he started out in
segregated society but during world war
two he was impressed by
some of these divisions in the Battle of
the Bulge and he thought this is an
absurd thing this segregation and he
would eat he did then integrate the
District of Columbia but Chief Justice
Warren thought that he never sarong me
enough supported the moral point maybe I
don't know but I do know that the point
that was going to get in the most
support was the support about rule of
federal law federal law supreme and what
he did is he said I'm going to send the
hundred and first airborne now we who
were born van and those older than me
know who these people were the hundred
and first airborne they were the
divisions that invaded Normandy that had
fought in the Battle of the Bulge there
were pictures in life magazine which I
can remember showing some of those
people with their parachutes open hung
up on steeples in Normandy where they
just were shot down because they didn't
land in quite the right place they were
heroes and so when he chose the hundred
and first airborne he knew he was
choosing and what Eisenhower did about a
week later September 23rd this is the
order i like the order i'll read you the
order as president of the united states
under and by virtue of the authority
vested in me by the constitution I do
command all persons engage in such
obstruction of justice to cease and
desist they're from and who disperse
forthwith that's what he read over the
radio so the people in the citizens
councils around the high schools could
hear it and then he sent the hundred and
first airborne 52 aircraft carrying
about a thousand troops they came from
Fort Campbell Kentucky and they landed
they landed into the rock and the next
day there is a new picture and the new
picture that went around the world is
the picture of those troops the hundred
and first airborne taking those children
into that white school fabulous
fabulous fabulous day for law in America
fabulous but I have to tell you it
doesn't have quite the happy ending that
I'd like it to have if in fact I could
only end here because I can't end here
what happened next was in fact things
went fairly well for a couple of months
a lot of the kids wouldn't speak to were
told by their parents don't talk to the
black students some broke that down the
teachers mostly tried to help some
didn't it work medium the kids were
sticking it out one got a loan no I
didn't through a bowl of chili over
somebody else's head which I don't blame
her for but by and large it was it was
ok then of course Eisenhower we had to
withdraw the troops at some point and he
did after a couple of months and pretty
soon who knows a lot of instigating
going on but the white citizens councils
were still there there was a lot of
pressure on the board all kinds of
things are going on in Little Rock and
before you know it the board comes up
with a plan to postpone the whole thing
for another couple of years and that
case gets into the court and eventually
it goes through the courts and then
after the event it gets to the Supreme
Court and there's the case of Cooper
versus Aaron now the Supreme Court's in
Washington they're not in Little Rock in
central high school and they have a huge
debate and still it's a great case it's
a great case why is why do I get so why
do I get excited about this case because
nine justices all signed an opinion
about what should happen next and they
said of course you're not going to
postpone this it isn't even close you're
not going to postpone it no and they
wrote down they wrote down several
propositions of law I'll read you one
this decision declared the basic
principle which decision Brown that the
federal judiciary is supreme in the
exposition of the law of the
Constitution
and that principal supreme that's the
first time disappears it didn't appear
in Marbury it didn't appear as who was
to have the last word here is where it
appears you see Marbury says in this
case we decide this the Constitution
Trump's the statute but he didn't say
what would happen in a similar case that
didn't get to the Supreme Court and he
didn't say that others had to follow it
but now the court says the federal
judiciary is supreme in the exposition
of the law of the Constitution and the
court was criticized a lot for having
said that well I think used to be
criticized a lot more than now I'm not
going to be criticized by me why because
I'm sitting there and saying well what
in heaven's name a supposed to do what
are they supposed to do they've just in
fact declared two years sooner that
there isn't going to be any more
segregation in the united states that
one-third of the country is really not
just out to lunch but beyond that and
they've got to change their ways and of
course i mean i can't imagine them
saying and by the way it's all up to
somebody else I mean whether whether
this really is the law not in analogous
cases they can't say something like that
if they're under an obligation to see
that this law as they've interpreted law
as they understand that in the
Constitution really is the law of the
United States hotspur's question
hotspur's quest and they had huge
debates that about where to go from that
what shall we actually do black was
saying say now now now everybody d
segregates now frankfurter said they've
discovered his papers it's so
interesting he said no no don't say
anything quite that radical the way
we're going the way we're going to get
this done is we are going to appeal
through reason to the graduates of the
Harvard Law School throughout the south
right all right that have some
absolutely there we are I mean that's
one way that's possible but but but this
is the cut how do we go and you can read
their debates how do we bring this about
how do we bring this about I'm not sure
how do we bring this about did help have
nine yes I'm sure did they reaffirm
Brown we're rumors around they said that
Brown isn't really the law all nine of
us say it's the law there are rumors
around that people can have private
schools or all kinds of other ways of
getting out of this we say they can't
they're rumors around that what we say
is not absolutely supreme indefinite in
interpreting law well it is and all nine
of us agree oh wait a minute is why is
this reading a little Hollow because i
have to say nine and remember our nine
or nine hundred or nine thousand and
what happened next what happened next
they issue that opinion and what
happened the next day they closed the
school closed none of the children went
to school and that was a lost year that
year for the children at Central High
laws black and white and a lot of them
were hurt a lot of them were hurt uh the
didn't go to college the football team
all wrote many many many years later
about what had happened that year to
them individually very interesting
article a lot of sad things happen to
them and some good some good that woman
with her face in rage she and Elizabeth
expec furred the black girl they spent
in later years touring the country
talking about Redemption that's nice I
like that I mean yes you can it's
possible and some good things came out
of that but basically what happened over
the next year is that school was closed
until people in Little Rock got fed up
with not having a school and they voted
for a school board that would reopen the
school and it was closed but they voted
for it and eventually the school board
the next year did reopen the school and
it was in fact integrated so what can
you say about sending these troops you
have to have a subjective reaction my
subjective reaction which I can't prove
and it comes maybe sitting in my seat or
whatever fabulous fabulous it helped to
turn a tide do I know that no because
there was so much 1955 was the year that
Rosa Parks sat in the bus there was
there was a lot that went on besides
what went on in the Supreme Court there
was a great deal set into motion and
much had to be done before progress was
made but it was made it was made and so
what I see that troop is being sent a
fabulous symbol a fabulous symbol a
symbol that the president of the United
States would support the court and would
support the court when in fact the court
made a declaration of law even where it
was tough politically to do so and
two-thirds of the South would voted
against him just because of that the
North was for him but we don't know what
the same strength and brownell right
Thank You mr. Brunelle and I do see that
as a great day for American law not
quite as definite as the judges in
Cooper V Aaron thought I mean that they
would just achieve what they wanted
because they didn't but still in those
two photos the one with the woman's face
filled with rage and the other with the
children being walked into the school in
those two photos I see that as a fulcrum
as a turning point
as a stage in a direction a direction
that law will prevail in America
including law that does much of what the
Constitution does which is to offer
protections for people who are not
popular offer protections for people who
are not in the majority and offer
protections for people in circumstances
where all of the votes would go the
other way in above it's in a sense if
you want to be a little overdramatic
about it President Eisenhower is
vindicating Hamilton I mean the decision
not to put this power in the legislature
but all that's debatable I'm just
telling a story very biased but
nonetheless telling the story now very
briefly take one other case final case
and you choose you choose which one you
want abortion that's a good one feelings
rise meaty roles yeah I was coming to
that Bush v Gore that's a great one that
is a great one for this point a very
good case for this point couldn't be
better the elections turning on a
knife-edge it looks as if Gore has won a
few more popular votes but the system is
the electoral votes and after all the
Electoral College is a mirror of
Congress senate and house together and
each state is to choose its electors in
the manner that the legislature of that
state shall decide and florida is
exactly divided my goodness it's close
and bush is slightly ahead and now
someone not me decides to file a paper
and ask the Supreme Court to review it
oh my goodness
well there were issues in that case
three members of the court not me
thought that the Florida Supreme Court
in asking for a recount demanding a
recount ordering a recount had so
departed from the statute of Florida
that it violated the proposition that
said the legislature of Florida shall
decide how to do this because it was the
judges of Florida now when i wrote about
that i was in dissent in that case i
said if you think that their decision is
not a normal judicial decision down
there in florida you haven't seen as
many decisions as i have I mean they're
all over the place and judge has come to
different conclusions on different
matters but that was descent three
thought it departed too far more than
three thought you'd indeed I thought
that if they're going to recount the
whole state they should have a single
standard and they shouldn't have one
County doing it one way another counter
doing it another way that's a debatable
proposition but the key in this was the
third point is his Florida going to be
allowed to continue five said no they
could not continue the recount for said
yes I was in the four did I feel
strongly about it well you never know
because for a judge to feel strongly
about something you know it like this is
not exactly the most emotional thing but
I did I did right I didn't think we
should take this case having taken it i
think we should dismiss it and if we
aren't going to dismiss it we should at
least decide it correctly and let them
continue with the recap that was the
view of four but the view of five was
different and indeed i said was a simple
referring back to what others have said
about red Scout to self-inflicted wound
that's pretty strong pretty strong so I
felt strongly sure for a judge did
people in the country feels strongly yes
very strongly very strongly
and yet i heard harry reid our Senate
Majority reader who is a Democrat say
this about the caves and I grew them he
said the most remarkable thing about
that case is a point that is very rarely
remarked and that is despite the
feelings that many of you may have had
that people all over the country head
but this opinion is completely wrong I
thought it was wrong despite that view
despite those feelings there were no
mobs in the streets there were no guns
there were no revolutions there weren't
paving stones being thrown at people it
was accepted and when Harry Reid said
that he was thinking this is all my
goodness but this is yes even here it is
an example of how 300 million people in
the united states have learned a way to
get along under law even when they think
it's wrong and that's when it counts no
even when they think it's wrong and when
it really might be wrong Wow and he's
thinking that characteristic which is
what I think is a national treasure
that's something that helps 300 million
people live together those 300 million i
began with those 300 million who are
there represented in that court and as
tough as it is to say that my goodness
that was so wrong somebody should have
done something about it the day you
start thinking and with guns and with
mobs and with wars that happens in many
countries and in our country who that
happened at one point and maybe that was
a good thing at that point you say these
things are not easy but balance yes it's
a trick it's a trick and we've seen that
come to the point where the
second most interesting thing that Harry
Reid said to me were the words and yet
not often remark and yet not often
remarked upon yes no we just breathe it
like the air oh we didn't think of that
we didn't think my goodness we accepted
it we thought it was awful what we went
along and accepted it and Vice President
Gore said to his staff I saw on
television don't trash the court thank
you thank you and that's not personal
that's not personal if you don't you
have to say the same as me the same
identical I'm just there is a trustee
you see now there we are a few little
cases brought out starting with that
Marberry Madison and Hamilton and
hotspur's question and what's
interesting to me about the cases is
both the development but how'd I how
much how am much uncertainty there is in
those I'm so glad we come up with Bush v
Gore because it's a beautiful test case
for what you really think what you think
should have happened for how hard it is
and perhaps in mind you how necessary it
is for us to live together in one
country under law under this document
even with a court that quite often may
make mistakes there wheel there we are
all right now that's the introduction
and I'm saying to you I can't bring this
about this situation that you've talked
about that i've talked about you are the
ones who will bring it about that's what
i want to tell those african judges I
want to tell that to the Latin Americans
I want to tell that to the Asians don't
talk to me talk to your own people it's
a question of Education it's a question
of habit it's a question of history it's
a question of learning how to get on
with people who think differently and
govern your different
is under law that's what this earth
lecture has been having said that I
don't think really the court has nothing
to do with it if the people has an
obligation and I think they do as we've
been talking about so does the court in
my opinion have an obligation to what to
help create what this was about so far
let's call it a workable Constitution
but that obligation and how you do it is
the subject of tomorrow's